[Music]
but
but that but the the alcohol is it's
it's well it's a hell of a it's a hell
of a drug man
yeah who knows like i mean if we had to
make a bad drug
legal the worst choice was alcohol
that's definitely the case
you know and i'm saying that as somewhat
of a fan of alcohol
yeah because alcohol is kind of an
escape into well it's not full
unconsciousness although it certainly
can be
but yeah an alcohol also makes people
aggressive it's the only drug we know
that
actually makes people aggressive so and
so so you see a massive
effect on crime rates because half the
people who murder someone
are drunk
and half the people who are murdered are
drunk
[Music]
and the funny thing is if you're trying
to stop drinking you need something
better than alcohol
yeah and it is then esteemable people do
esteemable things it's like yeah well
you want to figure out
you want to figure out something that
you're doing with your life that's worth
not getting drunk and screwing up
because you know you might say well why
do people drink too much it's like if
you like alcohol that's a stupid
question
you do stupid things when you're drunk
you hurt yourself
you compromise your health it's really
hard on the people around you you tend
to turn into a liar and it screws up
your life
yeah it's like yeah but it's pretty fun
yeah well it is but
you need something better than that and
what's better isn't
being straight and and and not making
mistakes it's like that's all
prohibition in some sense what's better
is
no you need an adventure man you need to
get out there and have something to do
and and something worth waking up for
and you need that's the substitute for
the addiction
actually the addiction is the substitute
for that if truth be known
yeah and you might also like the thing
too is you know i mean there's something
kind of
i don't know that the bar scene that
the heavy drinking scene there's
something kind of edgy about it you know
and something kind of adventurous about
it and you know you see that it's kind
of dramatized in people like tom waits
who's got that real hard edge or johnny
cash or people
hard living guys oh yeah yeah well
there's something kind of romantic about
that
and and fair enough you know but well
then what that means is you have to
build
something like that into your own life
so maybe you need to go
maybe you need to you know take an
adventurous trip now and then you've got
to have something there that
that that's that's edgy to replace that
so i have this program online called you
can find it at self
authoring.com or you can find it on my
website yeah but we'll put both the
links right here
okay so one of the programs the programs
help you write about your life
and by the way you don't have to be able
to write very well to do this and if you
do it badly that's just fine as long as
you do it because doing it is badly is
way better than not doing it at all
which is kind of like a motif for life
right get the hell out there and do it
you're not going to do it perfectly but
it's better than not doing it at all
you make your mistakes but you'll learn
one part of the program
which is the future authoring program
helps people develop a plan for their
life
you actually need a plan for your life
because the thing is the
plan gives you goals things to aim at
like imagine you went to the
the shooting range and you didn't have a
target well what the hell fun is that
what are you gonna do shoot your rifle
into the air
okay so first of all there's no game
without a target
all right so fine you need a target and
then you might say well is the game
worthwhile and the answer might be well
how how challenging
is the how challenging is the place that
you put the target
if it isn't challenging enough if it's
challenging enough the game will be
worthwhile
well there you go that's the secret to
life it's like if what you're aiming at
is challenging enough
the game will be worthwhile well it's
not worthwhile it's like well
reconfigure your aims then you're not
aiming high enough buy your own judgment
say well this isn't meaningful it's like
hey man
you're not aiming high enough because if
you were it would be meaningful yeah
that's the okay so while the future
authoring program says like look the
first thing you want to do is
decide that you're responsible for
taking care of yourself like you're
someone
hypothetically worthwhile okay so that's
the first thing it's like the same
imagine you have a kid and you like the
kid and you'd like things to go well for
them so you got to have that attitude
towards yourself right despite all your
flaws which are manifold
and that's hard for a lot of people to
get to oh god yes and no wonder because
you know
most of us are fixer-uppers and we need
some work and so it's not so easy to
come up with the whole self love which
is not something i'm not that
comfortable with anyways but
the fact that you're not perfect doesn't
mean that you aren't worth
improving okay so then the next thing is
so get yourself in that state of mind
just assume it
maybe there's something in me worth
redeeming all right next thing
assume that if you aim at it you might
at least be able to get close to it
okay right or that you'll aim at it and
miss but your aim will get better across
time and you're taking a shot in the
right direction yes that's exactly it
and you're starting to move in the right
direction and even if you haven't got
your
your goals specified properly as you
move towards them you'll get smarter
and you'll be able to make better goals
so you're on the right track starting to
calibrate you're starting to crawl
exactly what you're doing you're
starting to calibrate that's exactly it
and uh
then the next issue is okay now here's
another hypothesis
if you aim at it you might get it
but you're not going to get it if you
don't aim at it right you might not get
it if you aim at it but you might get it
so that's at least
setting up the preconditions right next
step
um imagine life three three to five
years down the road and you get
you get to have what you need and want
assuming you're reasonable
okay so these are things to consider
how would you like your family to be if
it could be the way you wanted it to be
what are you going to do with your
relationships with your siblings and
your parents
what about your kids and your wife your
intimate relationship
right if you could have what you wanted
what it would look like
your career or your job what's it going
to be and how are you going to conduct
yourself in it how are you going to
educate yourself because you're not as
smart as you could be you need to know
some more things
because unless your life's perfect
you're too ignorant that's basically the
issue
how are you going to take care of
yourself mentally and physically how are
you going to withstand the temptations
of drugs and alcohol
what are you gonna do outside of your
work that's productive
engaging and meaningful okay so that's
seven things it's just
even hypothetically if you could have
what you wanted what would it look like
okay next thing um write for 15 minutes
about what your life could be like in
three to five years
if you had what you want just so you
know
so do that next thing take stock of your
idiocies and weaknesses and assume that
in three to five years they auger you
into the ground and you were in the
worst hell you could design for yourself
that's probable write out that because
that gives you something to avoid
because when you're trying to you're
thinking well i have something difficult
to do why the hell should i bother it's
like oh yeah so i won't end up in that
hell
right right because part of it is well i
want to get to where i want to go
that's kind of nice and it's hopeful and
it makes you positive but that's not
enough
you also need to be terrified out of
your skull yeah and the only way to do
that properly well i'm sure this must
have happened when you decided to stop
drinking
you must have thought this isn't good
what did you foresee happening i thought
i wouldn't be funny i thought that
people wouldn't like me
i thought that um i wouldn't be able to
meet girls if i wasn't drinking or
right so that was what you were afraid
of giving up if you stopped drinking
right what were you afraid of happening
if you kept drinking
um i was afraid of not
achieving my dreams i was afraid of you
know uh
ending up a drug addict yeah of dying in
my sleep something you know dying under
the influence okay so there so
yeah it's not like that doesn't happen
to comedians right right
well and it happened to all sorts of
comedians and rock musicians usually
happens at about 27
you know weirdly enough so okay so you
were afraid you're afraid you're gonna
die or you're afraid you're gonna become
addicted so so let's say what what of
life what would have life like
being like you for for you if you were
addicted so you don't have a career
anymore no
right so you've given all that up and
failed so that's fun so that's gonna
drive you even more
towards drugs exactly is that so why
quit drinking
so i don't end up in hell hey there's a
reason there's a reason to stop and then
if you make that hell real
it's like here's all the details of my
personal hell
yes let's avoid that right so then you
have something to run the hell away from
you're also going to find out who your
friends are yeah because if you're
starting to put your life together and
you have friends that object
those are not friends those are just
people you know
they're not friends because a friend is
someone this is one of the hallmarks of
a friend here's two hallmarks
a friend is someone you can tell bad
news to and they won't tell you why
you're an idiot and
they won't interfere with your suffering
they'll just listen and maybe they'll
suffer along with you
okay so you can tell bad news to them
and they won't tell you some worst thing
that happened to them
they'll listen they'll suffer along with
you but a friend is also someone you can
tell good news to
and the friend will say wow in this veil
of tears
something good happened to you great man
i'm wonderful
it's rare it's unlikely good for you i
hope ten more things like that happen
and they're not envious and they're not
jealous and they're not one
up in you and if you're trying to get
your life together it's actually
if you're trying to get your life
together and your friends get in the way
that's actually real useful for you
because you've now identified who your
friends aren't
and you might think well i can't give
them up it's like oh yes you can and not
only
can you you should and it would be
better for them
because if they're aiming down and they
want you going down with them
there's nothing good about what's
happening to them and there's certainly
nothing good about that for you
yeah they're not gonna and then they're
gonna learn wow if i i'm gonna lose
friends if i continue in these
directions
yeah exactly exactly is it hard for why
is it hard for people to let go of
what's so
familiar with to them even if it's bad
well because it's complicated
you know and the thing that's a really
good question you discount the risk of
familiarity
that they're familiar with so like let's
say because people are in relationships
people are in relationships with the
drugs and alcohol people in
relationships with humans people are in
relationships with jobs people in
relationships with their own selves
and they live they're living a lie every
single day but it's yeah
it's familiarity yeah well you say i
have a job i hate
it's like well yeah but i'm not dying
from it's like not as bad as it can be
so you you kind of you kind of that you
factored in the risks already they get
invisible
you think well i can't jump out of this
job because what about all the risk
it's like yeah no kidding you've got to
make a you've got to get your resume in
order
you got to send it out you got to send
50 of the damn things out before anybody
will call you back
then you have to go get interviewed and
maybe you're not any good at that you
have to come up with a story well you're
a good employee and maybe and maybe
you're not yet so you have to figure out
how to do that it's like
what about all these risks if i go look
for a new job it's like yeah absolutely
man those are risks and they're harsh
and no wonder you're avoiding them what
about the risks for you to stay with
this job you absolutely hate
well let's think that through okay so i
have this dead end job i hate it i'm
getting better
where am i gonna be in five years i know
where because i've watched this with
people
you're gonna be you're going to be just
like you are now
except a lot more of what's good about
you is going to be gone and a lot more
of what's terrible is going to be
amplified
and you're going to be like in five
years you're going to be 10 years older
instead of three years older
yeah right because it kills your spirits
yeah so it's like
you think oh my god there's a terrible
risk in pursuing this new job it's like
yeah there is a terrible risk
there's a terrible risk and you stand
with your job right now and so one of
the things that's really
really freeing to understand is that
you're screwed no matter what you do
there's no secure path forward
give it up it's risk everywhere oh my
god that's terrible it's like yes
except for two things you can pick your
risk
that's the first thing so you get to
pick your poison that's something and
second you're a lot tougher than you
think
so even though there's risk everywhere
if you confront it
forthrightly what you'll find is that
you can actually handle the risk
and that's the security well alcohol
alcohol really is a good drug for coping
with anxiety that's why people use it so
it does too if you if you really like
alcohol it does
it does two things to you it makes you
more extroverted and enthusiastic
while you're on the ascending limb of
the blood alcohol curve which is why you
have to keep drinking
once you start because if you plateau
that goes away so you got to keep
drinking
okay so that's one thing it makes you
more enthusiastic and and
more full of positive emotion and the
second thing it does is reduce anxiety
yeah and so if you are a bit
more socially anxious and you also have
that positive response to alcohol which
everyone doesn't have by the way
then it's a great drug but the problem
is it's well
it's a great drug for the moment well it
also
alcohol is an interesting drug because
it it it actually doesn't make people
stupid this is being tested like
alcohol people who are drunk will take
far more risk and you might say well
that's because they're too stupid to
understand the risk it's like no they're
not
if you ask them about the risk when
they're drunk they can outline it
perfectly
what it stops them from doing is caring
about the risk it's actually and that's
part of the anti-anxiety components like
yeah the risk is that's why you can
drive around
drunk at high speed in a car which is
really stupid thing to do yeah
we used to do that in the back roads in
northern alberta it's fun
you know but but people died all the
time doing it especially in the winter
it's like wow this is great it's
great until your head's going through
the windshield you know like so many
things
yeah it's like jumping off a cliff it's
i'm flying which is true until the last
one tenth of a second
it's like then you're not flying man
it's like yeah yeah so
so alcohol alcohol has exactly that
effect it is a great
anti-anxiety drug but it does stop you
and he said it stopped you from learning
the skills that you need in the social
circumstance to be able to cope with
that
so then it actually stops you from
dealing with the anxiety you don't have
to learn
how to overcome it that's not good yeah
um responsibility the
the the the willingness to shoulder
responsibility
which is part of what factors into
achievement and ambition
it's really the really the part of it
that's only positive
is being confused with tyranny and
oppression and so that men are
in in large part being punished for
their for their best impulses right you
want to get out there and like do
something it's like well doing things
wrecks the earth
right it's like well the earth is
wrecking us so it's only just that we
you know that we defend ourselves a
little bit but it's also just wrong
it's like that that willingness to go
out there and contend with the world to
go on your adventure
right and to take the risks and the
entrepreneurial risks and the risks of
discipline and the risks of
responsibility
and to and to buttress and support the
family system and
and the community system that's all
incredibly laudable
but for me it's more than that because i
think of it as a bulwark against
hell and i mean i mean that both
literally and metaphysically it's like
it's actually vital that you take your
place in the world and
you find a meaningful responsible path
forward because
it's in that pathway that you find the
meaning in your life and that buttresses
you against the catastrophe of life and
if you have if you don't have that you
have the aimlessness
and the suffering and the pointlessness
and your own malevolence and bitterness
it's it's hell yeah and then you make
hell for you and you make hell for your
family and you make hell for the
community it's like none of that's good
and so whenever i see people step away
from that they're
moving forward and they're telling me
about it i think and i really think
great that's a miracle man keep it up
like it's really important and i don't
care what you're doing